Hans what have we learned in the last 24
hours about why we think the SNB made
this decision
well the interventions got to be too
costly that's an easy one right they
didn't want to defend and they had some
500 billion Swiss francs and foreign
reserve it got too expensive Thomas
Jordan he is the SMB prank that bank
president most unpopular man in
Switzerland right now here's the
headline knee fall that's you know on
his knees before the speculators there's
a view in Switzerland that this is going
to crater the economy you could have a
recession here leave alone what that
does to exports the big pharmaceuticals
everyone's still sifting through and Tom
Brendan the message I have this morning
no one knows just how bad it's going to
be we've got a couple more weeks before
this all shakes out guys Hans you're
standing on the munster bridge there to
your left you have the financial
district to your right Zurich old town
where the tourists go which of these
sectors of the Swiss economy is going to
be hit the worst the finance industry or
the tourists
well touristy in a way that's
predictable right I mean I was on my
plane down from Berlin last night with a
bunch of skiers and they were all
moaning about hasn't suddenly their
vacation got 20% more expensive we don't
quite know the financial industries
exposure yet yeah a few online trading
platforms have gone bust or at least one
New Zealand there's one here in
Switzerland has announced a big loss we
don't quite know the exposure at least
to the Swiss banks that they have and
then when you look at Switzerland Inc
the big companies the AV bees the
pharmaceuticals you know we have to wait
to see what is come in and how much how
well their hedge so open questions
tourism though that's an easy one down
20%
bad for Tom and his drinking at the
Belvedere in Davos and just a few days
anything about the Cronin Holland sir oh
I was gonna say not to say anything
about the piano bar in Davos but that's
another story the good news is that
Davos you can put a lot of it on the
AMEX
really really I didn't know that
Bloomberg watch this show next seriously
we heard from the CEO of swatch
yesterday he said he has no words he
described this as a tsunami for
exporters what are you hearing from
Swiss businesses about the move
Swiss businesses especially in the Swiss
mental stunn these are the small and
medium sized businesses they are
looking about cuts a bite that means
part-time work for some of their
employers so I mean some of these guys
they're so labor-intensive a lot of this
fine craftsmanship that you get in both
Swiss industry and elsewhere in the
economy it's labor intensive and those
labor intensive products for example
Swiss Army watches right they make those
here they have to pay salaries in Swiss
francs
ditto coffee machine makers and all of
them for the most part export abroad 56%
of Swiss exports go to the European
Union Hansie ft has a nice summary of
the distinction between Hungary and
Poland is their real estate markets are
linked very much to the Swiss franc in
Poland and folks this chart is very
important it shows that not the move is
not the same against each country
this is Danzig Gdansk we have 117
percent depreciation problem over the
last three years Poland gets crushed off
this don't they well it's because a lot
of poles took out took out home
mortgages that were denominated in Swiss
francs right but message this and this
is maybe the longer-term issue for the
global economy right yes this is Swiss
specific you could have a recession here
the larger question is our central
bankers more not just infallible do they
sometimes totally get wrong calls and if
we think going forward with whatever
happens with the Fed whatever happens
with Mario Draghi in quantitative easing
this isn't exactly a vote of confidence
for Federal Reserve and central bankers
central bankers make mistakes in the
case of Switzerland they may have made a
pretty big one
Hans you spend most your time in Berlin
analyzing the Germans soul I'm gonna
read you a German reaction to the move
yesterday this is Christian lips of Nord
Elbe that's a bank writing in Hondo's
blot what you need to know about the
franc the SNB seems no longer to believe
that the ECB quantitative easing will
work and with this panicked reaction
could have maneuvered into a dead end
Hans is that just German
wish-fulfillment no I mean part of it is
like the Germans we just have to say the
same line coming out that all the
deflation is all related look this was a
peremptory move on anticipating
quantitative easing the last time the
Swiss National Bank put out made a move
on say changing the negative for deposit
rate they did
on the same day that we expected it was
time for January 22nd what happens in
January 26 when you guys will be in
Davos I'll be in Frankfort standing
outside of the ECB this is very related
to Mario Draghi does in Frankfort
Hun's Nichols thank you so much from
Zurich